[Music]
tiger king a fiction based on some true
stories
and there are some big truths in there
like that carol baskin killed her
husband
one thing it definitely is not is a
documentary oh this joe guy is an
absolute scumbag look at this carol
basket wait a minute this other doc
guy's got 28
wives a womanizer seems like maybe i'm
i'm treating them wrong
these girls live large and yes i have
been dating some of them for decades
i just happen to see a trailer for tiger
king and i was like
what is going on did you ever get paid
or no all kinds of places around the
world have tiger king fever it's a
runaway hit
all of a sudden the most hated person in
the world became
carol basket how certain are you she
killed her husband
does sardine oil work i've got to get
that going right now which do you prefer
animals or human beings
i lived on a lot of big hollywood sets i
made ace ventura and
jungle book and duck two little all the
guys i know that do that
are girl crazy now i don't count joe
exotic
right now with the corona out no tourism
has happened
there are so many wildlife facilities
that are in dire straits what are the
laws right now with private ownership to
own a tiger can somebody want a tiger
today in us or no
you get up close and personal with these
animals and you'll have an experience
like
no one else in the world
[Music]
thirty seconds did you ever think you
were making it
why would you bet on goliath when we got
bet david valuetainment giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we gain no value to haters how they run
homie look what i become
i'm the i'm the one
[Music]
in q1 of 2020 netflix
gained 15 million new subscribers or up
to 183 million
subscribers worldwide and one of the
reasons
is a show called tiger king of which my
guest
today was one of the three main
characters of the show
and that's bhagavan dog and tohu doc
anto who is the founder and director of
the institute for greatly endangered
and rare species aka tigers
he runs the ritz carlton of tiger
sanctuaries doc thank you for being a
guest on vitamin today
thank you thanks for having me so so let
me ask you i mean i i had a chance i'm
at
work one of my graphic designers nancy
is talking about tiger king
pat you got to watch it it's amazing the
story of joe exotic so
they go and create a meme of me dressed
as joe exotic i still have no clue
what's going on they posted on instagram
everybody's thinking i watched it then i
said look you know let me see what these
guys are talking i watched the first
episode one night i find myself
you know staying up to three o'clock in
the morning watching this flipping show
of tiger king i couldn't believe i did
that so
have you had a chance to watch the whole
thing beginning to end
yeah i got to watch it you know i took
the time and looked through it it's a
quite the salacious sensationalism ride
you know
one thing it definitely is not is a
documentary
it is just a wild tv ride made by some
really good editors
so one thing it's really not as a
documentary wow so you would call it
is this one of those things qualified to
say uh
uh a document a a fiction based on some
true stories
yeah you know a docudrama it's a it's a
it's a great
tale and there are some big truths in
there like that carol baskin killed her
husband
you know there's some big points big
powerful parts but there's a whole lot
of
tall tale that's getting rolled along as
well so
has it done good for you has it done
like when it came out were you happy
this was coming out or were you kind of
like indifferent about it
i mean it was a disaster in certain ways
it made a lot of
outrageous claims against us and what we
do and how we what we're really working
on
i worked on another program for three
years it was a hbo
show about uh environmental protection
about tiger conservation
um it included richard branson on his
lemur conservation program
and a guy that was a turtle conservation
guy we were
doing a whole program of how private
people were able to
produce great results for worldwide
conservation
we worked on that for a few years and
then uh
this march i just happened to see a
trailer for tiger king
and i saw i was in it and i was like
what is going on
and i called up the director producer um
eric gooden said
what the heck's happening here dude this
is this looks like i'm in this and i did
not give you permission for that i have
a contract with you
for absolutely not this what's happening
and you know he went oh well they took
it from me it all went away
i bulk sold everything i made this
special with you
then i made this other stuff with joe
exotic and i went and interviewed carol
the two weren't really supposed to mix
up but uh the guys who produced
for netflix um the show fire
festival which was really yes train
wreck
crazy thing as well yes that guy took
all the information
he edited it and he made the show out of
it
eric the producer director he claimed it
was out of my hands
they took it away it's not my fault
don't worry about it
did you ever get paid or no no never
done get out of here
nothing now you've been kidding me it's
just
it just this fell off the mat
went rolling along and i told him how
can you do this you know
we don't have papers for this we only
have the original show
and it says a one use only on the
contract
and so you know it's all going to be
greater minds than mine that will fight
it out and decide
who gets a dollar so i know i know uh
joe exotic has got what 94 million
dollar lawsuit he has against them i
know a bunch of things are happening
like that
are you doing something with these guys
or no you're just kind of leaving it out
because it's bringing a bunch of
marketing to you
well i mean yes i've got guys i'm just
trying to get paid for all of my footage
and all of the work they did
gathered up images from programs i've
done for the last 25 years
they pulled them off of an ftp site and
then just
stacked them into a show when i never
told them they could use a
single image and the show's filled with
that so many images on the show
of tiger people are me over the last
35 years there's images of me as a kid
working all kinds of big cats on there
and i don't think people even can
recognize it because
now i'm an ofg i'm an old fat and gray
now
and uh when i had that big shock of
black hair
and huge mustachio i look like a
different guy yeah but you still got the
look though
i can still see the fact that you were
you're a stud with women it's very
obvious you got the charmander you got
the looks
so by the way do you know the number how
much money these guys made off it or no
i haven't heard a cash figure i mean i
heard 78 million people have watched it
so far
i think it depends on how you do the
click you know there's a click
where you saw part of it and there's the
click where you benched it and
knocked down the seven hours so i guess
it just depends on whose uh
statistics you're looking at but it's a
runaway hit
certainly the biggest things in the
world these days i get a lot of contact
from
australia from england from the
netherlands all kinds of places around
the world
um are are have tiger king fever uh
so so uh chappelle got paid what chapel
got paid 60 million for his special i
believe i think seinfeld is now getting
paid like 120 or something like that
and that's for one hour think about it
so this is seven hours
and i don't even think they got as many
downloads as you guys got so if that's
the case the numbers got to be a
reasonable number
on what they're getting paid with it
yeah again this
the story you're watching this you're
kind of at first you're like oh this joe
guy is an absolute scumbag they're like
oh my gosh joe's a good guy
look at this carol baskin wait a minute
this other dark guy this womanizer has
got 28
wives this guy who believes in polygamy
and look at so it's going back and forth
and i did some research and i noticed
based on what i'm reading you don't have
three four five six wives these are just
girlfriends of yours or women that live
on the campus with you or some of them
are employees so
what's the real story here you know we
have this big family here there's 25 of
us that live here we live here because
we also have a hundred big cats
that we're working all the time big
adult lions and tigers we make full
contact with all the time
that requires people to have real strong
relationships with those animals
they have to be seeing them every day
the team has to get together to take
them in
to bring them out wandering the forest
with them whatever it is we're working
on
and so that team is a live-in team about
half that team are my relatives my son
and my daughter
and my other daughter their children my
nieces nephews my mama lives here
a bunch of us are that family that live
here and run the facility
that other people have come on came on
when they were young have stayed for
decades
because it's an incredible lifestyle an
incredible opportunity
to be exposed to wildlife in such a
different way than anywhere else in the
world
so from that there have been a variety
of ladies that have come
in they live here they work here and
they take care of stuff
and yes i have been dating some of them
for decades
and they all know about each other of
course we're all hanging out here
it's just uh not exactly what everybody
else thinks of
as a normal lifestyle but but you are a
qualified womanizer would you say that
would you say you're good with women i
mean
that smile i can see that smiles work
many times
i don't i don't know that that's a
womanizer that gets a little bit
negative you know
i hope i'm a charming guy and with women
but
a womanizer seems like maybe i'm i'm
treating them wrong these girls live
large their lives are big and great
they're super
talented earners they're characters that
go out and work so hard
they benefit from it themselves her
family come and live with them
the girl chyna who's on the show uh
she's there
and she's got her sister living with her
they've helped run things with me here
for the last 20 years they're
super quality ladies that just make the
whole thing rob
so so i would assume i am 41 right now
okay i got an eight-year-old a
six-year-old and a three-year-old i got
a three-year-old daughter
i am very thankful for there not to have
been instagram or snapchat when i was 18
19 20 years old because
i just don't want any of that stuff to
be seen by my kids because if they see
some of the footage
they're gonna have to explain themselves
why that's their grandpa or anything
like that
that's some of that priority with the
wording and the language and the life
you lived as you get older kind of like
well you know i don't want to talk about
it right now i'm a grandfather i got
kids i got grandkids
i don't need to bring that up is that
kind of what phase your aunt
sure to some extent certainly 20 years
ago i'm 60
when i was 40 years old life was more
footloose and fancy free
i traveled way more i lived on a lot of
big hollywood sets i made ace ventura
and
jungle book and doctor doolittle i lived
out hollywood a lot of the time i
traveled around the world and did a lot
of different films and stuff
so of course you know you're in your 30s
and 40s it's a different life than you
are in your 50s and 60s
and you know things are slower and
faster according to
you know how engaged you really want to
be running amok
and you know i found fabulous girls who
stayed on
you know for decades and they're so
reliable and so
good at their job they are able to take
care of my other kids which are these
big chimpanzees and orangutans and
elephants and tigers and
they make the stability of those
relationships
which are very extensive you know every
single night
we have sit down dinner with giant
chimpanzees
they come in we cook dinner with them
they sit at the table
and that's why we're the last ones in
the western world that has these great
big apes
that come in and interact with us it's a
it's a bygone era that anybody even
knows how to do that
any longer which do you prefer animals
or human beings
people are phenomenal we have emotion
and we have capacity to be
incredibly cool most people are lost in
their sauce
and are living on social media and they
don't know which way's up
so those guys i'd rather hang out with
an elephant or a monkey
but if you're really living to your
ability well you have this incredible
insight into the creation and all the
things that are so great about it
there's nothing like great human art to
inspire
but i love a chimpanzee to come down and
uh
eat a orange with him and let just how
much he likes his orange is pretty
amazing
that's got to be cool not now to some of
the guys that are watching this
maybe they want to get a few tips from
you they don't have tigers to brag with
women they don't have chimpanzees
what what kind of tips would you give to
single men
who aspire to have a little bit of a
game in their life that maybe they're
not that good at it right now they want
some tips maybe it's a
it's a friend of yours maybe it's a
younger son of yours who's struggling
with women
what advice do you give to men on how to
you know go out there and be decent with
women
well there's two sides to it there's the
simple premise of be good
do good be kind be compassionate if
you're stable
everything around you becomes far more
stable
the the really difficult thing that no
one wants to hear
um of how on earth you have two
girlfriends at once and they know about
each other is
you have to be incredibly blatantly
honest
from the very beginning that's not how
relationships form
we tell these great big fairy tales that
we watched on disney
and we've helped people full of these
fantasical tales of
how it should be could be how we feel
indole
nothing's there and um i think that that
destroys a lot of relationships
so blatantly honest is the hardest thing
and is the only thing
to make those lifelong connections so so
when you have two relationships you just
kind of tell them listen i'm an open
relationship type of guy here's where
i'm at has that kind of been your
approach
not exactly but you know a more uh we
just have this big family and
and within this big family there is so
many jobs and so much stuff to do
you are welcome to be here live this
life and do the stuff you want a
relationship with me
uh that would be just grand but you
don't nobody's forced no one has to do
anything
you want to be involved you can be
involved if you don't
it's hot in this kitchen and you can
certainly leave and it's that way every
day
it's a very intense situation to think
that these great big 600 pound 8 foot
tall guys
are coming out and interacting with us
every day it's really a military series
of maneuvers
every day how to open the door just how
to
come around and exist with this type of
precision makes you have an incredibly
intimate connected relationship
with anyone that you're doing that with
you must rely on them
so heavily and you have to get timing
with them it's like a
perfect ballet and you're doing that
perfect valet
day and day and day in and out and if
you screw it up
someone's going to believe maybe
someone's going to die
and you can't allow that so the
relationship is really
thick in so many different ways where
you're relying on people
in a manner that 99.999
of humanity never approaches this type
of lifestyle
or do they want it's too intense it's
too precise
people want life to be a little more
free and simple and flowing
ours is that way with very rigorous
rules
and i think that that helps make it all
work out what's the worst accident you
guys ever had on your part
really driving in cars right getting
getting
having somebody rear-end me at 70 miles
an hour at a stop sign
on sunset boulevard in miami boom you
know collapsing the back of the car
giving everybody
whiplash headaches and trauma and drama
and unfortunately i've been in probably
five
serious car accidents where i wasn't
driving and that's the worst thing
that's happened to me
with big cats we virtually had nothing
happen
i got all my fingers i got i still got
everything in place
um we're very careful with what we do
and
we've had the great opportunity to know
a couple hundred tigers over the last 40
years and out of those
we found dozens who love to do the work
they want to go out with us they want to
swim they want to go in the forest
they love the new sights and sounds and
smells
those big hats are incredibly connected
to us
the ones who don't like it then those
don't
have to be out with us and maybe they
move on and live at some beautiful zoo
somewhere
or do something else if they think that
uh people aren't their best buddies now
let me ask you for me i'm big on asking
birthdays like if i'm interviewing
somebody you can't ask in job interviews
but i'm always curious to know where
your birthday is you know when you're
born when you're doing this
how much how much do you see a trend
with people
who like certain type of animals and how
their personality is
dog people cat people tiger people
chimpanzee or people who don't like
animals or like birds
have you seen a trend with that yourself
since you're in that world or not at all
you mean like like they're a leo or a
sagittarius no no no what i mean was
like a
a you know dog people you trust tiger
people you got to be careful
you know cat people you got to be
careful with tiger people are
independent like
have you noticed a trend there with
people or not at all
sure every guy i know that has
a real full-time work one-on-one with
tigers which i mean i've only known a
dozen in my life
there can't be but a few dozen in the
world everybody i know like that
is pretty much very centered on their
own life
they're not very social they don't go
out they don't go do stuff
they rarely drink they just are not a
guy that is out doing stuff they live
a very centered personal life mo all the
guys i know that do that
are girl crazy now i don't count joe
exotic because
that guy's not a tiger guy that guy's
scared of tigers he doesn't have great
big tigers that love him he doesn't have
a relationship with numerous big cats
and other wildlife
he doesn't have wildlife that respect
him and that he enriching their lives
is his high value activity for us we
have those big guys out running
a high speed lure going 40 miles an hour
across a
whole track we've built for them that's
a regular occurrence
out the open for our tours at the myrtle
beach safari and also
just for enriching activity we have
several huge pools and ponds
and we swim every few days we've got big
tigers in the pool
little cubs learning to swim and we do
that activity with them
joe is in another world joe is about joe
joe was
looking for the world's greatest party
you know he was
he was trying to find it in the midst of
that he od'd on drugs a few times
he made and spent millions joe had a lot
of money when he started you know the
joe i met 15 years ago he had brand new
everything bought anything he wanted
he had some old oil money from texas
that was his family money
and uh he blew through a lot of it and
in the end uh the snitch
jeff lowe and probably the other guys
that were there
involved um they kind of bled that last
money off of and he went
broke had a public defender for a murder
for hire for charge which i think uh
helped get him a 22-year sentence but
you know jack
lowe with james garrettson they kind of
bled out the last of that i think from
joe's uh last stand there in oklahoma
before he ran off to florida
now have you joe and carol ever been in
the same place together
no we never have i've never met carol
carol's been attacking me
viciously for decades this lady has just
had a thorn that she's just been stabbed
with that has
my name on it i guess she's always been
after me even though our place
is literally a hundred times nicer than
hers bigger more beautiful incredible
setup
such great healthy beautiful animals
carol's really had a very hard time
uh showing anybody anything but a
derelict run-down
junkyard of a place i mean places across
america i've seen i've seen hundreds of
them
versus the worst one in the country wow
you know there's no place as back
woodsy funky as that joe had way too
many animals and way too tight of his
face
he had some nice habitats and a few
things set up but mostly at a dog pound
where it was
habitat after habitat after habitat too
small
and the animals are boxed up you know so
i've never really
got to deal with carol at all except in
uh sending her
notifications from attorneys to take
down uh images and letters and ideas
that she's put up a few times
and joe i met a few different times
through the zoo
industry him he was trying to improve
his facility he was contacting people
that i
was helping out about how to have better
food how to have better habitat
how to build things better um for the
big cats we talked about that
and then five six years ago he came to
myrtle beach
and he actually because myrtle beach is
a tourist town with 20 million visitors
and it was a big circus show in town joe
supplied some tigers for that circus
magic
show and uh they had trouble where they
were keeping them what was happening
people were complaining so we went down
and looked at all of it said hey what's
like how's this all going
and we can help you with bigger space
maybe get your animals outside
do something else for you then the show
closed down but in the interim i had to
deal with him a few times
went to dinner with him one time just to
talk about it next door to the
big theater that was here in town and uh
i had you know that was my biggest joe
experience during that time his staff
were all around
and they came through our attraction the
myrtle beach safari
and they saw the attraction and took
tours and he was like that's what i want
i need to build a place just like that
from that reference
a lot of people think that we're uh
friends somehow that he says i'm his
mentor which
i think i mentor to people all over the
world who want to build world-class
facility
because ours is just of that scale and
we've had the time and opportunity to
put tens of millions of dollars into a
single place which makes it have a lot
of flash
and a lot of incredible habitat
doc if you're if you're the best in your
world who's the second best in your
world
there are single habitats that are
really well set up
at several zoos you know that i've seen
got it
the stuff they do at busch gardens in
tampa is a beautiful setup
i think there's been several places that
have built great setups but
nobody else does what we do the other
place i see personally
that look beautiful over and over you
can't say the name right is latif
mccoon's place
who is the president king whatever it is
of um united arab emirates he has an
incredible facility there it looks like
you know he's
dropped 100 million on it i mean it's
exquisite and the animals look
incredibly well cared for
i have mutual friends who work there and
and live
there and i think that that place is run
world class
but when when you were building your
business what was your uh you know
like a business model you were saying
i'm going to be good in this area this
is where i'm going to win
i'm going to focus on this area what was
your vision with the company and the
business you were building what was
going to be your number one focus
in the beginning in the early 80s you
know i started out um really just doing
uh just having that first couple of
tigers
i was working for exxon oil who's the
big oil company who used to have a tiger
as their
mascot put a tiger in your tank they
were my biggest patron
and i helped them work on their tiger
conservation program
i started running up more of a tiger
conservation program with them
the exxon valdez crashed the big old
uh oil tanker that they got in so much
trouble for
they were environmentally the bad guys
they quit the tiger business
i took on everything that they were
doing and ran it myself
from there right at that same time of
being the exxon tiger guy
hollywood contacted me at link and asked
me to come work for them
and i went and did a 500 movie and
television jobs great big fortune 500
ads
and i produced that stuff like that
saying ace ventura jungle book dr
doolittle might be so young
and some great big flops like the
gardens of stone francis ford coppola
worked on it for a year incredible big
film
no one ever hardly saw it but i learned
a ton
by watching how that movie was made i
did the same thing with dino de
laurentiis with a movie called date with
an angel
just being on the set and watching how
they produced and light it and do it
i got a real good feel for presentation
of wildlife
in a way from there things like making
eddie murphy into dr doolittle and jim
carrey and
the pet detective i said i could do that
for everyone
i could create a vibe at my place where
you get to feel like you're dr doolittle
you get up close and personal with these
animals in an incredible perfect setting
beautiful jungle habitat nothing that
looks like
a set of cages everything natural and
organic not like a zoo
which is designed to have hundreds of
thousands of people come
we're having 10 000 people come in an
entire year super limited
premium experience and that motto was
for me to make
what you saw here look like the perfect
set of a movie
where you would feel like if you were
there you had
landed in shangri-la people i want them
to pull up and say
god i wish i lived here and that's not
what you do when you go to the zoo you
might say i'd love to have those animals
but you don't say oh this is where i
wish i live
when people come here they're like this
is the coolest pool
the greatest fire pit the most
incredible
buildings the coolest place to hang out
and just chill
is just right here the great food the
vibe
whole five-star experience that is what
i was pushing towards
i also stole some of that from going to
five-star resorts
going to the malamala preserve in africa
which is this the greatest most pristine
piece of uh
property in africa the presentation of
how well they treat you
how they're always there with a drink
with a cool or hot towel
to wipe your hands off with or cool your
neck and i
took a lot of those ideas and applied
those to the experience that the
preserve
being this five-star exquisite
experience where you're just in the
jungle you always wish you could have
visited
so only ten thousand per year that's
about all we can handle yeah
a regular tour is maybe 35 to 55 people
you know right now with the covet just
edging off the governor just gave us
permission to open back up
some of these are going to have 10
people those 10 people are going to get
a heck of an exclusive
you know more people should uh take
advantage of this one moment
probably by summer with tiger king fever
uh you know every tour will be full
so are your ticket prices still six
hundred dollars are you going to raise
them
my ticket is very much like an airline
ticket of its 339 to come in
and it's dynamically priced as the tour
becomes fuller
the price escalates so that the tour
doesn't get too full
and so that each day is able to have a
set amount of people where it's still
profitable but not where we're just
going to
have 200 people come on a tour we're
always going to stop before we hit
capacity
so what's high low lowest is 339 what's
the most outpathed ticket
639 okay got it three and you could buy
a photo package and other stuff it can
it can get quite expensive
but it's nothing like taking a trip to
africa
you know i take people every year to
africa that's twelve thousand dollars a
person to go to africa
it's nothing like a nice vacated
thailand where you might see some tigers
and elephants but
not in the luxury you do here and you're
not going to get in and out of thailand
for five grand even if you're on a
budget
and that's a third world country where
things are cheap so
it's a bargain if you're just coming
with your a family of four and you can
probably get in and out for a couple of
grand
and you'll have an experience like no
one else in the world
tons of celebrities have come and done
it and uh tons of people that are just
real avid wildlife um enthusiasts that
want the most
out of their experience who are some of
the who are some of the people that have
come to a park
sheesh i mean you get you can see some
of the beautiful shots i have beyonce
kissing my chimps you know and i have uh
oh adama kasu the great big linebacker
was down came swimming and played with
bubbles the elephant
uh man i'm bad with names um
any presidents anybody mayweather came
and hung out
i saw jimmy carter one time he came and
saw me i saw
um president bush one time saw us as
well but i went and saw them
at events okay i didn't do it um you
know i've had kings and queens from
around the world meet me at events
because i go and do wildlife fundraising
events and i show up with elephants or
pimps or tigers and i have people
interact and meet them
and therefore open up their hearts and
minds to wildlife and their wallet
and get them to donate to international
wildlife conservation like what we run
the rarespeciesfund.org or
the big international groups that we
team up with to try and get
new policies passed new laws put into
place
to protect wildlife around the world
i like to hold twelve thousand dollars
for one person to go with you to africa
right so it's twelve thousand
so and how many people do you go with
when you do that
our trips to africa max i think is about
35 the most we ever took
usually it's about 15 to 20 people go
with us every fall we take a trip there
it is a life-changing slice of africa
because 99 of africa
is overloaded and overpriced and you
don't get to see the good stuff
but the right piece of africa it's like
you are
shaking the hand of god you're connected
to a wildlife
pristine environment that seems like
this could be eden it is so
unique but even in africa it's 99
gone the wildlife of africa is on the
brink wildlife across
asia and africa both are having
incredible trouble
and wildlife conservation is in dire
need over there and right now with the
corona out
no tourism has happened there are so
many wildlife facilities that are in
dire straits animals are even starving
to death and dying because
no one's come by to hand over that
dollar for an experience wow that's
master money that makes the east run
so you're seeing you're seeing the
effects of coronavirus also hurting
animals not just businesses so animals
are taking hit as well
i think thousands of animals are dying
poaching is through the roof
you know the poachers are out there
taking advantage of everybody being
hidden out
and poaching is rampant across africa
and asia i mean
it is big big business how are you being
affected by the pandemic
i mean easter is an incredible time in
myrtle beach often the town of myrtle
beach which has 150 000 hotel rooms
is no rooms available in the entire town
you can get a million people here over
the easter season
and we have no one here it just dried up
and we have to stay at home order all
business is closed mandatory
so you're just uh sitting here staring
at an incredible facility that's just
devoid of people and devoid of that
income so
it's been super costly and uh it is
painful we hope it'll
turn around we're talking about opening
the beaches in the next days or for sure
in the next couple weeks we're
we're waiting for the governor to make
new ideas
so how are you keeping your team sane
how do you keep them
calm during these times how are you
talking to them what are you telling
them
fortunately we live on a 50-acre
preserve where there's just beautiful
open space and we're just we're still
swimming we still all had family cookout
time and easter and we live along this
big beautiful river
we used to let the elephant go down
there and swim and play the big thing
that changed is the boats fly by on the
big river it's a
500 foot wide river they scream out
carol killed her husband
over and over tiger king but a whole lot
of carol did it i mean that's the mantra
of the season so
so how certain are you she killed her
husband
i don't have a video but i've
seen the stuff that's poured out from
the show and i've been on this story for
the last 15 plus years it sure
seems like carol did it whether she
covered him in sardine oil or not that
might be a
question but if she did do it seems like
fruit from watching all this information
roll in
now would that be an effective way of
doing it would that would that actually
work if she did do that with sardine oil
or cod liver
whatever it is i've never tried it i
meant to do it
i need to do an experiment for social
media i need to you know maybe put one
shoe with sardine oil on it and one with
the
chanel number five and it would get tens
of millions of views
i need to do it does sardine oil work
i've got to get that going right now
so since since you're uh you know you're
good with women
lincoln once said you know the best
thing to do uh with an
enemy is turn them into a friend have
you ever tried to uh
make carol a friend the first couple
times that she attacked me
i was running my program in miami i've
had a show that ran down there for 15
years
and she attacked that show because i was
i guess closer to her backyard
she wasn't as popular as she has been
lately well
free tiger king different kind of
popularity now
and she just wrote this outrageous
slanderous article into the miami herald
and i wrote her back and said i'm sorry
you are deeply confused
she was just talking about the poor
quality of care and facility and place
and like
there's nowhere like us there's no vets
that like our vets there's no facility
like our place
you've made a mistake she wouldn't even
respond she just wants to have that one
track
mind of i am the mother teresa of all
cats
and everybody but me is doing it wrong
especially if you make contact
she's just of that vibe like so many
it's too
dangerous to do this it cannot be done
safely
i'm 40 years of doing it entirely
day in and day out i've had more than
one million guests make contact with big
adult tigers
because my adult tigers met guests until
after the siegfried roy um meltdown that
took place
i always let my big adult tigers meet
guests and i have tigers wandering
through crowds for
so many feature films and on so many
movie sets
and she says that can't be done well of
course it can it's a joke
i've done it for my entire life and
carol just wants it to be something else
it's a matter of teamwork and skill
and understanding the rules and the
language of the wildlife you're exposed
to
the real experts that i know have had no
accidents
there are people that do but every time
something comes up
it's there's a secondary problem there's
substance abuse there's somebody
uh too far too tired they brought a
person in that they knew
shouldn't be there and that person um
got hurt
no one's ever been killed by a random
tiger except at the san francisco zoo
where the guys on christmas day some
time ago maybe a decade ago
were playing around on christmas day
they had a bb gun they were smoking dope
they were kicking and hanging out
and somehow at the very end of the day a
tiger climbed out
and ripped up three of them and killed
one of them
and that's the only place and so that
tiger was in a habitat in a place doors
closed
of what's supposed to be a world-class
zoo so
tigers are incredibly reliable if you
know the rules just like driving
right i got friends and family members
have died driving
everybody knows somebody's been in a
terrible car accident
if you go to the store today and you
decide to drive there backwards
you probably have an accident if you pay
attention to all the rules it's less
tigers are the same thing
the rules are just more complicated but
you can follow along
and accidents with tigers need not
happen
why do you think power many powerful men
have this desire to own a white tiger
you know what
what what is it what do you think it is
is it a control thing is it a
they relate is it i feel like i'm also
you know
somebody that's of power what do you
think it is with this infatuation of big
tigers
i think you get two things a tiger is
ultimate sexy beast you look at him and
he is
magnificent to touch him he feels magic
is
his hair is always perfectly clean he
feels amazingly strong
and beautiful even as a cub he's super
cool and he maintains that throughout
his life but just gets bigger and bolder
i think that people love that are
attracted to them
but i also think what takes place is
people who have already
had a lot and done a lot like mike tyson
he's already king of the world so much
is going on he says
i've got this you know indulgent
lifestyle that i'm spending millions of
dollars a year i'm living in a house
that's tens of millions of dollars
what accoutrement would be the next
super cool thing
i think tiger comes to mind for a
certain
kind of quality of life a certain class
of guy
says i'd like to have a tiger live here
it would be super cool the problem is
nobody goes about understanding the
rules
first so they can't develop a
relationship with that tiger
they also don't understand the
incredible amount of time
but they don't devote themselves to the
tiger enough the tiger's a year old it's
250 300 pounds
and it's biting and it's and it's
jumping and if you're mike tyson
it's too much no one's ready to really
fight an
eight foot tall 600 pound guy it's got
10 knives like wolverine
implanted in his hands he's too much
he's got to really love
what you're doing with him or you're
going down doesn't matter who you are
so so big part of it is attention
because i know you said earlier when i
ask you about people that own tigers
you say you know dozens of them and most
of their personalities are they're very
to themselves you know they put the time
into the
into the tigers and all of that so for
private ownership
what are the laws right now with private
ownership to own a tiger can somebody
want a tiger today in us or no
only in a few states i mean in south
carolina where i am it's illegal
in most of the states certainly all of
new england it's been illegal for a long
time
there's a few places alabama uh maybe
nevada um i think there's four or five
states that are the only ones left where
you can privately keep a tiger
if you have tons of money michael
jackson had private tigers and private
gyms
in california of all crazy places
because he has unlimited access to funds
if you have unlimited access to funds
you build a zoo you put it wherever you
want you put in zoo staff you bring in
superiors
you bring in animal trainers and it can
be whatever you want
if you want to blow millions of dollars
a year at it mike tyson did something
similar
but he got a little shafted and hired
people that hoodwinked him and
bought got the wrong stuff in the wrong
people in the wrong way
what's next for you i mean i know
obviously you run your business here are
you working on any major projects any
major things that's coming up obviously
outside of the pandemic that was taking
place
the preserve here is always growing you
know we just finished an incredible
great ape house we have 12 great apes
orangutans and chimps and
gibbons that all live up there that's
our our in-house project you know what's
got to be done right now is
there's got to be tiger king 2 needs to
be king 2
the truth and i think that there's room
for that i think we're
i have a lot of people approaching us on
how to put it together
i think that there's some good pieces in
there that'll happen i think the myrtle
beach safari youtube channel
may have information coming up about it
soon um
we're hoping that something else can be
done because there's a lot of unanswered
questions a lot of stuff there
i don't know if we're gonna get any new
footage of joe but uh
you never know have you a lot of our
guys talk about how close
carol baskin looks to hillary clinton
have you seen that as well or know that
that picture going around with the two
of them
oh yeah you get that right stare and
that right kind of like
i'm coming for you look um they're both
pretty spooky girls i mean
the two of those women are are highly
intense
and seem like uh if you do something
wrong
you might wind up covered in sardine oil
imagine if they ran a company together
what it would look like
nobody would want to mess with them that
would be too much
so maybe if because i heard somebody
open the case and they're now
investigating here again i don't know if
there's any truth behind that or not
is it i've heard the case is open i
think that you can see a lot of the
information
on um bcr watch dot com
that's like a watchdog site for carol
baskin and all things big
rescue and i believe the sheriff has
opened the case back up i think there's
new reward money out there i think that
a woman came forward and said i was
married to the hit man
and put an affidavit out who knows how
it all goes
i think her for her to go to prison for
murder without a body
25 years later probably pretty
complicated not normally happens
in the united states i don't know if
that goes on if that happens
i think there's definitely going to be a
need for tiger king 2
if that happens because people will not
i mean they can't wait for that
all of a sudden for a couple months the
most hated person in the world became
carol baskin i don't know how that
happens but it is what it is
so let's do a quick speed round uh doc
i'm going to give you a couple names
tell me the first word that comes to
your mind
all right rick kirkham
entertainment tonight i'm not sure if
that was what it was but he seems that
dude
michael murdock don't know okay
alan glover belongs in that bathtub he
just you should have stayed there
jeff loho snitch snitches need stitches
joe exotic a lost
lonely guy with a silver spoon that just
went way too far
with the help of those same snitches how
about howard baskin
he's kind of like uh a pair of sandals
with socks on it just doesn't quite look
or fit right
last one carol baskin
oh my god i mean just just satan's ilk
for big cats i mean just been the worst
thing in the world for them
destroying the species destroying
people's understanding of them
just uh big cat satan big cat satan
carol baskin
well if if anything formulates and
builds up i'm sure the
i'm sure i know for a fact 75 78 million
people
can't wait for part two if something
happens with her now i'm uh
hoping this investigation goes a little
deeper i'm sure there's a lot of other
people want to see what happens with the
end of the story but like you said 25
years
it's kind of tough to do there's a
couple things i want to do i want to put
the link below
to what you do every year when you're
going with that 12 000
sounds like an interesting trip if
anybody wants to know we'll put the link
on where they can find it you'll give us
the link we'll put it below
and then the second thing is for those
of you guys that are wanting to go to
that bcrwatch.com
we'll put that link below as well and
then obviously another link to find
doc and his tiger sanctuary the ritz
carlton of tiger sanctuaries
in myrtle beach uh south carolina having
said that doc thank you so much for
making the time for
being a guest on valuetainment thank you
come on out you bring those kids bring
your wife come
see this experience it's life-changing
come try it i look forward to it i look
forward to it
so if you've seen tiger king this gives
you a complete different perspective of
it especially coming from an angle of
how we felt about
joe or carol or himself and his stories
and the tigers and peta
and all these different angles we took
but if you've never seen tiger king my
camera guy right back here
he said you know it's crazy i don't even
know if i want to watch it or if i do i
think it kind of became a spoiler alert
all i can tell you is this was a very
weird story and i did it because many of
you asked for it i have two other
interviews if you like this one i have
two other
interviews i want you to watch one is
with detective greg kating
who was the lead detective investigating
on who killed biggie and tupac and
very technical you have to see the route
we took with this interview here and the
other one is with
the number one card magician in the
world he doesn't like to be called card
magician
card mechanic there's a very special
surprise with this story here
richard turner if you've not seen this
one you click over here and if you're
not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye